[Music]
with the Lord and we have a special
guest in the round today Lord
Jameson how you doing sir CBC throwback
action this guy he's one of the pioneers
in film this is what we used to do back
in the day man salute to the crew and
all that but we just came out of
spider-man far from home and we've got a
lot to discuss real quick so he's gonna
break it down with raw reaction spoiler
cast if you haven't seen it already
please do not watch this because this is
not for you go see it so we just came
out of it so I'm gonna start with low
Jameson
we just sort of film and to post-credits
what are your thoughts sir I mean I'm
still processing it right you know I
would say the first thing that comes to
mind is I watched homecoming a little
like a couple days ago just sort of prep
for this yeah and I really I mean all
the flash and spectacle and everything
is great you always expect that in these
Marvel movies top notch but I think what
they do with the character moments and
all the kids in the high school man that
is what makes these movies really really
good the humor the the the emotion like
the relationship they're building with
MJ like I don't know I can
everybody's got CG everybody can make
big explosions and even though part of
the movie is about sort of all that
being fake yeah which is cool which
school that was good at was incredible
it was a big twist to see all that and
to get inside of it but that was sort of
my first reaction was man they they know
what they're doing with the kids and the
characters and you just enjoy everybody
and everybody that's playing those
characters and Tom Holland man let me
jump in I mean this is different my
perspective coming from the first one
which was homecoming is I'll be honest
like I knew they had the character and
had the rights right
so I knew that they were gonna approach
it differently by not doing
the typical origin story and all I get
that part so but the only thing I
struggle with what part one was just
that I was tired of Peter being like
Papa stark prophet star you know every
five minutes I was I wanted him to build
it I felt this movie started to bridge
him on his own and I love the MJ
relationship I love Holly and my pen how
they handled it and just like with the
reveal of the identity you don't say I
felt that needed to happen cuz it's like
so it was a little too common cookie
like no one knows where he's at
come on you're like you know say like
somebody he does it so that part was
interesting to see how they was gonna
handle that when I was gonna go with
that was for the most part well done I
must admit I I didn't know what to
expect I liked the movie I've really
felt too heated up towards the end and
again um some key moments for me I think
was the happy situation the glasses the
handing it over to him for a reason now
we're gonna get to the post credit I'll
get to that later but once you like give
me some key moments for Lord Jameson
that really stood out for you that you
liked see I mean really so III have had
friends of mine accused me of liking NYU
movies because I went to NYU and I
always used to try to get my friends to
watch these smaller independent movies
everyone loves the big blockbusters I
love them too but really like I it was
those smaller interactions that really
like the first movie they said it was
inspired by John Waters movies back in
the 80s and like and that really to me
is like the the relationship with to him
and Ned and just all those little more
interaction the flash like that really
honestly is the part that I enjoy the
most it hasn't I'm grinning ear-to-ear
as those kids are sort of navigating
Europe I mean Martin stars
like a guy who can carry his own movie
is like a side character here who's
really really great so and also the tiny
details that sort of have Kevin and fate
I don't know how to pronounce like the
legendary disperse March is great I
loved his fingerprints on it right like
when they first revealed Mysterio and
they started cutting back to like these
characters are from the older mole that
was dope like I mean that is just they
are the web is so intricate and they
just are so well thought out
that bald actors actually and they like
the whole Mysterio thing with him being
like almost like a jilted Tec lover who
who's been shunned and now it's like I
need to take this stuff but I really
like that approach I didn't know where
they were going with his origin story
I'm not the biggest Mysterio guy but I
felt his inclusion the way they handled
that I thought was cool cuz I was like I
didn't know what to make of Gyllenhaal
coming into the world I see the face oh
well I was just trying to remember right
now I feel like I'm giving a sense of
deja vu you know I mean didn't they
basically use the same principle in Iron
Man 3 where what's-his-face one thing I
didn't like oh let's just nitpick again
again cuz I want to spider-man here's my
perspective I would the spider-man
characters shine right I want you to see
cuz he's a powerful character in his own
right so I guess like the explanation or
non explanation of the spider the Peter
tingle
let's just get like I'll just like okay
why doesn't he have that ability right
now I don't feel that was properly
explained you know I was just curious I
just did you catch anything with that so
I mean they haven't I actually kind of
like the way they dealt with it because
you know I think it's I think it's
almost overly common to explain
everything okay
oh really explain everything and
sometimes you get bogged down in those
explanations and those explanations lots
of times disappoint people
sometimes just good for a movie to just
show something and not you were okay
with him not having his natural ability
remember it he had it in endgame
remember you know his he didn't quite
know to make of it they're dealing with
it a little bit in the beginning when
they Peter tingle so obviously it's
there it wasn't fully developed okay
okay but the fact that they forced him
to really like figure that out and the
way they did it as a way to sort of like
fight these illusions I actually thought
that was really well done it just forced
him to bring those to the forefront no
there for me also some cool part to I
thought there was some cool toy Tony
Stark throwbacks
I thought they pay homage to the
character in a lot of ways um I much I
was okay wait I didn't I mean there's a
little freaky part with their like the
the Mysterio resurrection part low
freaky I love it but as far as like I
mean look at the end of the day Tony
Stark is my Connick character for the
MCU and literally as be honest I'm
insane DMC let's call it what it is that
first Iron Man we would not be here to
all these you know films if that had
happened so I knew there was gonna be
some payoff you know I'm saying by the
end of the day I still felt the way the
movie progressed I thought Peter Parker
the spider-man character was finally
getting developed finally being able to
show that he can kind of stand on his
own and that's what I wanted to see cuz
at the end of the day I knew look they
got the rights from Sony we know what
that's about right we know contractually
so I just wanted them to now build him
so that his next film okay it's Hamid
it's not this over-reliance I mean guess
he's gonna have the tech but not these
over reliance on a father character to
say hey help me what do I do
you all the time that's all I would you
they say go for it yeah I mean a couple
things about that I totally agree I mean
he's our characters that deserves to
shine a hundred percent of the spotlight
on his own he's big enough and he has
enough enough to do that so it's
definitely time for him to get there and
this movie pretty clearly was like sort
of that a bridge bridge but the other
thing
the other thing and I agree like with
the whole zombie Ironman thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
so something interesting about about
Marvel getting the rights to two
spider-man so if this movie didn't make
a billion dollars yeah clearly so now
they get one more movie right and the
future beyond that is not entirely clear
that is true so I don't know I it will
be really curious to see where they take
it from here obviously they have big
ideas with the post-credits and
everything but ya know I mean that the
the boardroom stuff is really
fascinating you know most people aren't
talking about that stuff but it really I
mean let's say in some alternate
universe this movie doesn't make a
billion dollars like so let's get to as
far as like on the post cranes things
drop now I know
Jameson has not seen Captain Marvel and
I believe or some parts but um you know
I was very surprised where they went
with this this post-credits so initial
reaction from me was that Nick Fury and
homegirl are Scrolls we were they were
all along
and clearly Nick Fury is on vacation
clearly he's not doing his job and these
guys were the standings now just to get
you up to speed
um again I couldn't call her too much
because I know he still intend on seeing
Kevin so can I go in okay so here's the
thing so basically the scrolls the
scrolls basically you know the way the
story was portrayed was to actually that
they are the ones had been taken from
their world and stuff like that they're
still the shapeshifters but they were
kind of painted in Captain Marvel
initially as these evil race that
shapeshifter know but the reality is the
Kree kind of forced them from there so
they're kind of a sympathetic figure
Marvel has changed a narrative and made
the scrolls the sympathetic feature and
then they ended up being kind of
befriended by Captain Marvel at the end
and helping out towards the end of her
film so now this relationship with um
fearing on she could see it it's broaden
and stuff like that so now he's in space
and there seems to be more of a cosmic
presence now with him so I'm curious to
see where that's gonna because I'm a big
surfer fan and I was told I need to
watch this right now I mean I'm gonna
have to watch it again just showing some
affected to get all the connections and
I'm saying but this is definitely
setting up Nick Fury in a cosmic fury
like a almost like a cosmic I don't say
police but he's out there he's clearly
monitoring stuff so that's what I got
from it you know I know you didn't get
him a bull just what was your feeling by
seeing all that stuff first of all if
I'm not mistaken we watched Fantastic
Four Silver Surfer the legendary rise of
the Silver Surfer Fox's greatest lover
just I'm a fan boy it was trash I was
surfing we did probably yeah no I mean I
love the dig I always loved the cosmic
stuff I love that they're expanding I
mean eternal and the queer do they get
the crazy earth again I love the visual
the visuals they used at the end
Mysterio actually doing all the love
when you just go you sorta like break
down the walls so I love the cosmic
stuff like that obviously that looks
like they're going more in that
direction and to circle back to one
other thing that you said that I also
want to point out spider-man coming into
his own at the end they're like I feel
like they're finally starting to know
spider-man's abilities yes these movies
never have really been able to get him
just full throttle Walla but just really
being as agile and quick oh I think I
don't know where I feel overall it can I
say he's the best friend there's certain
aspects of harm that I really enjoy and
but I will say I felt like just the
agility the nailing just a use of his
abilities towards the end of this film
I'm
dad spider-man that's what I want to see
that's you know saying that kind of
thing and for me personally I go fine it
was a little feel-good II with the MJ
thing because I'm like that that needed
to advance for me and I'm like you know
see and I like that I felt the
relationship was built naturally and it
felt right I didn't feel like ah you
know I'm saying kind of thing like this
was forced or cheesy kind of thing and I
like you know I was cooler so I was
gonna ask you this before we all start
really ready to wrap as far as forget
forget I mean look spider-man 3 killed
Toby
I mean I can't there's a is that fault I
like Toby to Andrew Garfield but like
the that's more of an ultimate version
right like scheme warning a classic
diminutive small like you know he's Toby
was more of the some people like Toby's
Spidey and I believe some people like
Garfield's Parker or well actually the
opposite around scuse me this guy's
Parker and which called Spidey because I
felt like I like Garfield Spidey with
the joke and while he's fighting and
doing all that stuff I thought that's
kind of Spidey in the comics but um I
don't know I'll be I don't even like huh
I loved it yeah I'm just curious to hear
you say it
because some people feel exactly the way
you feel I put it this way we haven't
had a bad spinning so right so I mean
it's really all about it's all about a
matter of personal preference and taste
like I don't think Toby's great Garfield
I is Holland the number one for you I
just I mean I feel like he is I have he
encapsulate so in the interview I'm
gonna get there look at there in the
hierarchy of spider-man films where is
this I know it's early with Rory
accident we know we we prisoners in a
moment
so what do we feel like as far as
spider-man but just compare it to the
last one it's not with the last one is
this better
it's far from home better than
homecoming good reaction yes
homecoming before I watched it again I
honestly forgot about a decent amount of
it other than enjoying it which is
actually kind of a common issue with
movies like you enjoy them but they
don't really like a good friend of mine
oh and if you ever watch this he calls
them the movies empty carbs like you
know I could say the same thing about so
so yeah I mean I went back and watched
it again I was like oh this is really
fun but this I don't know I feel like it
was a little bit better my best is
Freddy - okay this is a tough one um I
think definitely I like this better than
oh I'm homecoming you know homecoming I
did I hated it I understood why it was
necessary and how they handle it and the
inclusion of the character how
complicated was to put him into that
universe with all the contractual stuff
so I looked at it from a contract I was
like that's a good job of how they did
it and he didn't go the typical origin
story route this now is more character
development what I want to see the
evolution of spider-man I'm like yes so
I'm good with that
as far as defiled a holic you filming on
spot with the Highland thing oh wow I
like Thailand I don't know if I'm ready
to give him the title yet I don't know
but he's really good he's really good
people morph you just have a face so
look that's pretty much what I got Brown
Taylor who's gonna wrap this thing up
but overall your feelings with
everything with a foster body man formal
also I want to give a shout out to JK
Simmons for the cam here with the loo
that was nice so no other things told I
had a great time really enjoyed it
always do with these Marvel films and I
mean what they did with the first person
that I've seen
they're obviously like really really big
so I like how they're pushing things
forward and
pretty aggressively could they can be
sitting on their laurels when they're
not they're pushing it overall as the I
pick staff is hurrying us out of here
we're gonna wrap this up but yeah
roundtable reviews wid Lord Jameson
spider-man far from home I really
enjoyed it fantastic film I think like
mojama said this sets up the cosmic
universe we're gonna see what it goes
let's hopefully my man surfer is coming
so I'm excited and that's all we are
R&R with the Lords another successful
one and we
[Music]